who is the glomide queen if you're like
me this is a question you never asked
through your entire first playthrough i
had never heard any dialogue read any
item descriptions or held the attention
span required to even notice that there
was a mention of a gloam-eyed queen then
i started to hunt for more answers
regarding the godskin characters and
what is meant by the phrase destined
death which is mentioned quite often by
melano and malakath so here's what i
found out while lore hunting in elden
ring these videos are meant to be fun
speculation and to start discussions
that can lead to other interesting
theories so please discuss calmly and
respectfully down in the comments also
youtube told me that 98 of people that
watch my videos are not subscribed which
made me very sad so hit the subscribe
button so i can stop crying myself to
sleep at night thank you so let's get
into the video let's start by reading
some item descriptions regarding the
glomide queen i started with reading the
descriptions of godskin weapons spells
and armor sets the godskin apostle set
reads the apostles once said to serve
destined death are wielders of the god
slain black flame but after their defeat
by malakath the blackblade the source of
their power was sealed away the god
slayer's greatsword reads sacred sword
of the dust-eyed queen who controlled
the godskin apostles before her defeat
at the hands of malakath the black
flames protection spell reads the
apostles were all embraced by the
glomide queen and the black flame was
their armor within here's what we
learned from these three items one the
glomide queen and her apostles served
destined death two she was well loved by
her apostles and gave them the power to
defend themselves against gods three
when malakath defeated them and sealed
away destined death he also took that
power from them we can also take from
all of this that the glomide queen was
the previous guardian of destin death
before malakath we now know that
malaketh defeated her and sealed it away
upon queen america's request but who is
or was the gloam-eyed queen reading the
black flame ritual spell says the
glomide queen led the apostles it is
said that she was an imperian chosen by
the fingers so from this we can narrow
it down slightly we know that she is
full imperium the same as mykola melania
and ronnie we know that her time in the
lands between was during the age of the
golden order since she was assisted by
her own fingers we can also assume that
the glomide queen is likely one of
america's direct offspring since being
an emperian is only possible from this
at least that's the only way we know how
one can become an empirian but if this
is the case why would queen america send
malakath to defeat one of her own kids
and seal away destined death well the
most likely theory is that queen merica
feared death itself or
feared what the glomide queen wanted to
do with destined death in hand the black
flame monk armor reads the black flame
monks enthralled by the god slain black
flame became traitors abandon their
posts as guardians the seduction of a
taboo is never easily spurned so here's
a couple of ways we can interpret this
description 1. the glomide queen and her
followers began abusing the role as
godslayers or 2 the glomide queen's
followers turned against her now in my
opinion neither of these really matter
in the grand scheme of things the point
is that this family cult team whatever
you want to call it with the glomide
queen broke apart and left her
vulnerable it's possible that she was
defeated by her own followers after they
sided with malaka this could be why the
godskin duo and the maleketh boss fights
are in the same area of pharaoh azula
they're super close together so with all
of this information in mind i believe
that the gloam-eyed queen is melana the
glomide queen was empyrean guided by the
greater will assisted by the two fingers
and was the previous guardian of
destined death i think this dialogue by
melina pretty much proves her to be the
glomide queen
me
i'm searching
for my purpose
given to me by my mother inside the
urgery
long ago
for the reason that i yet live
burned
and bodyless
she was given her purpose from her
mother inside the urgery which almost
100 percent has to be queen america she
lost her purpose long ago which was
likely to protect destin death she also
states that although she is burned and
bodiless she still lives
burned meaning possibly burned by the
black flame of her previous followers
almost everything points to melano being
the glomide queen and if you aren't
convinced yet listen to what she says if
you inherit the frenzied flame
you
have inherited the frenzied flame
a pity
you are no longer fit
our journey together
ends here
and remember
should you rise as the lord of chaos
i will kill you
as sure as night follows day
such is my duty
for allowing you the strength of runes
she says her duty is to kill the lord of
chaos and if you go through with the
flame of frenzy ending she says this
lord or frenzied flame
i will seek you
as far as you may travel
to deliver you what is yours
destined death
so let's sum up everything we've learned
melano was born of queen america at the
foot of the urgery and given a purpose
by the greater will which was to
disperse destined death to all equally
throughout the lands between so either
she got too ambitious with this power or
queen america started getting
anti-greater will and queen america felt
threatened she commanded meliketh to
take the power of destined death from
melania and seal it away malaketh
defeated her and removed her
gloam-colored eye and her body was burnt
using the black flame of her previous
followers this would explain why one of
melania's eyes are missing and if we
look at the beast eye it looks like a
faded out gloam color that reminds me a
lot of mel in his eye in the flame of
frenzy ending this act by queen america
was likely the first action taken
against the golden order which led to
everything else spiraling out of control
in the lands between and eventually
started the shattering of eldon ring i
truly believe melina is the glomide
queen and is a much more important
character in the story of elden ring
itself than i ever could have imagined
however let's get a bit deeper with this
queen america was herself an emperian
empyrean can be interpreted as a title
or something born from a great rune
itself ronnie seems to be born of a
great rune the one that ratagon gives to
rinala it's possible that the glomide
queen was born from the rune of death
maybe she was the rune of death so when
ronnie stole a fragment of the rune of
death she also stole a fragment of the
glomide queen by offering her body and
godwin's soul to death ronnie brought
back the glomide queen in the form of
melania because godwin and ronnie were
used in this process melania still
shares a lot of connections between them
one she still has burn marks on her body
because ronnie's body was burned two she
is still somehow connected to ronnie's
soul as shown by her face being stuck to
ronnie's face three she is still somehow
connected to godwin's body through the
roots of the earth tree godwin's body
spreads the death roots maybe this is
what allows melanoma to walk the lands
between and why she gets stronger when
we get closer to the er tree it's all
possible that after we release the rune
of death from malakath the glomide queen
received all of her powers back so maybe
the melanoma we see in the frenzied
flame ending is no longer melano but the
glomide queen herself
let me know what you guys think down in
the comments again don't forget to
subscribe to the channel it helps me out
a lot thank you so much for all the
support i'll keep making videos if you
guys keep watching them have a great
rest of your day and i'll see you all in
the next video take care